تخيلوا معي ان سر نجاح العلاقه الزوجيه
يكمن في كلمه واحده هكذا يبدو الامر سهلا
انها كلمه نرددها يوميا ولعده مرات مع
زملائنا في العمل او الاشخاص المستطرقين
في حياتنا اليوميه لكن هذه الكلمه تحمل من
التقدير الكثير ما يجعل علاقتنا بالشريك
مزدهره
هذا الحديث لم ياتي من فراغ انها دراسه
علميه اجراها معهد جوت مان لعلم النفس
شملت 40 الف حالتي زواج على مدار 50 عاما
اكدت نتائجها ان العلاقه الزوجيه الفريده
بنيت اساسا على كلمتي شكرا
سالنا بعض الازواج ان كانوا يتبادلون
كلمات الشكر والامتنان في علاقاتهم وهل
اسهمت هذه العبارات بانجاح علاقاتهم
العلاقه الزوجيه اللي اللي بين الزوجين
نسبه الكلمات الشكر بين الزوجين
تعزز العلاقه الابديه همم بين الزوجين
الحقيقيه بين الزوجين بشكل صادق بيناتهم
وتزيد الى زياده الموده والمحبه بين
الطرفين كلمات الشكر وكلمات العرفان
وكلمات الامتنان مهمه بكل العلاقات يعني
لكن العلاقه الزوجيه احيانا
بعض الازواج فاقدين هذه الكلمات
لن اقول لكم تعالوا لنتغاضى عن سلبيات
بعضنا البعض لكن لا باس لو ركزنا
بالايجابيات قليلا ومن اللطيف جدا ان
نعترف بجهد الاخر والمثير بالاهتمام ان
الدراسه ذاتها اكدت ان لكلمات الشكر دورا
مهما بالحد من ارتفاع نسبه الطلاق زينب
المشهد صباح العربيه بغداد